summer Gardens farmers markets and
roadside produce stands all make us feel
closer to the food that we're eating
knowing exactly where the beef in our
burgers or the Cucumbers for last
season's pickles came from adds a little
magic to something we have a tendency to
take for granted but is it possible for
personal Gardens and local producers to
feed us all
[Music]
hi I'm Melissa from Southland Organics
where we provide natural solutions to
Natural problems for lawn garden and
Coop care learn more about these
Solutions at southenorganics.com
no matter how you get the food you eat
one thing is for certain that process
looks immensely different than anything
we could have predicted 10 000 years ago
or even a hundred years ago imagine with
me living in a time where the only real
access to food was whatever the family
had growing in the yard could trade with
close neighbors or relatives or had
storage from previous seasons and what
about a time where you had no home or no
crop to harvest where everything you ate
came from hunting and Gathering
today an ever-changing web of food
products ensures that there is a near
constant supply of easily accessible
food this was removed most of the
regionality dependence on growing season
and unpredictability that was for a very
long time associated with food
availability after Decades of
infrastructure and development our food
supply chain has morphed from local
operations to a global Enterprise
according to USDA reports the United
States is the world's second largest
agriculture Trader behind the European
Union
in 2022 agriculture products accounted
for 196 billion dollars in exports more
than triple the 62.8 billion from 1997.
a large portion of exports are what the
USDA considers high value products or
hpvs these include dairy products Meats
fruits and vegetables these massive
increases in agriculture exports have
been made possible by increasing demand
and elimination of trade barriers trade
barriers to Canada and Mexico were
eliminated by the North American Free
Trade Agreement or NAFTA which made it
possible to quadruple exports to both of
those countries even the products that
stay in the U.S are destined for travel
for example let's think about a fan
favorite chicken whether it's nuggets
wings or whole Birds if you're eating
chicken grown in America there's a
strong possibility that it was grown
right here in Georgia where we produce
the most meat chickens in any state in
the country
this enhanced international market for
agriculture products has offered
American farmers a new outlet to impact
food supply globally as well as a
stronger sense of security and their
ability to sell their end products but
it's not without its own problems from
Transportation shortages to trade
agreements producers are impacted by
issues that arise at all levels of this
intricate supply chain along with the
normal risks associated with producing
High volumes of crops or livestock like
disease and natural disasters this
doesn't begin to cover the social and
cultural challenges producers are facing
as consumer Intrigue and backlash grows
recently the agriculture industry has
been facing a new question from
consumers how do we know that our food
is safe and nutritious although This
Global Food Market has opened new doors
for producers consumers have begun to
question whether or not they can trust
the food that they're buying at the
grocery store due to high volumes being
produced the many stops it makes between
the farm and the kitchen tables and the
environmental impact from commercial
production these concerns have paved the
way for what some may consider a
revolution of local eaters and
homesteaders who believe that growing
your own food or buying from a trusted
local producer can provide an
alternative this way you know not only
where your food came from but also
exactly who grew it and how as this
demand for presumably higher quality
food source has grown dedicated Facebook
groups farmers markets on-farm stores
and roadside stands have steadily
increased in number now instead of going
to the grocery store and buying a steak
that came from somewhere in the U.S
there's an option to buy beef from a
producer 20 miles away and know exactly
what the animal was fed it's breed and
where it was raised and consumers are
loving it in fact more than nine billion
dollars in agriculture Revenue could be
attributed to local cells a fresh and
value-added products like butter and
cheese in 2020. within this movement
there are some with more drastic beliefs
that locally grown food is the only
option to ensure safety sustainability
and nourishment but is that an option if
we wanted to could we go back to a time
where Global Enterprise didn't determine
our food supply could we feed ourselves
solely through local sales and trade
let's take a closer look estimations can
be made for the amount of land needed to
provide food for a single person based
on nutritional need
conservative estimates say that one
person can produce enough fruits and
vegetables for a year on about 3.25
Acres now before we go any further let's
remember that this number doesn't take
into account any crop losses or
inopportune weather conditions which is
not uncommon when growing food in the
United States alone the 2022 census
reported 333 million 287
557 people but for Simplicity we'll use
333 million if each person needs 3.25
Acres that would mean a grand total of
over a billion acres of land at first
glance that seems like it wouldn't be a
problem since the United States covers
more than 2.3 billion Acres the
complicated part of the equation is when
you start to consider space already
covered by cities bodies of water homes
and land that's not suitable for growing
food like mountains deserts and marshes
taking all this into account you start
to realize that the land mass we have
available to us is simple simply not
enough for us to grow substantial enough
food supply for us all to feed ourselves
without some form of commercial
Agriculture and this is a theme that's
echoed globally the truth is there's not
a simple or a single answer for some
growing their own food is a way of life
a passion and a sustainable practice but
for others this may not ever be an
option because of time space and
physical ability there are even folks
like me that lie somewhere in between I
grow a summer garden and love every bit
of food it provides for me my family and
my friends I never shy away from an
opportunity to support a local producer
but I also value the ability to walk
into a grocery store and purchase the
things I wouldn't otherwise be able to
enjoy
we live at a time where food has become
incredibly more accessible than it was
for Generations before us we're
connected to Global Market simply
through the food that we eat and we're
lucky to have the opportunity to make a
choice between growing our own foods and
buying the food provided for us by
hard-working Farmers across the globe
homegrown local or commercial the choice
for your family is in your hands if you
have any questions feel free to email me
at Alyssa southorganics.com call
800-608-3755 or comment on this video
keep up with us on social media at
Southern Organics thanks so much for
watching I hope that this video can
provide you with a bit of clarity when
it comes to making the right decisions
for your family's food
foreign
[Music]